loved working with him back in the day
at ESPN he's a three-time manager of the
year he is Buck Showalter how are you
sir
Rich Eisen how we looking we're looking
good we're looking good bug you tell us
you tell us every time I watch the
postgame show anywhere yes I think about
you and I sitting on a set at Yankee
Stadium after everybody's left at one
o'clock in morning reason yeah and we
look at each other go really I know and
we were the ones who this the 2001 World
Series we're the ones who I think we we
got that we had to get on a plane we
miss game 2 so we could be there for
Game three of that World Series which
was particularly moving because
obviously that was the the game 3 where
George Bush threw out the first pitch
and the stadium was just absolutely
abuzz with so much more than just
baseball that that was just oh that
wasn't a I'll never forget hanging with
you buck at that World Series yeah life
life was simple that's why you know I'll
probably go back on the field well you
know what it's around wondering are you
are you in the in the middle of some of
these conversations between teams
looking for managers right now you know
talk about publicly like a lot of people
seem to be comfortable with but I you
know I have a lot of respect I really
bothers me to riches when people are
talking about jobs that people currently
have right I think it's very
disrespectful obviously there's these
jobs open you know I wish there weren't
I don't want anybody to lose their job
it's painful and I just you know our
game to be better I wanted to learn from
some of the challenges we're going
through and you know whatever capacity
whether it's TV or or doing the rich
guys and so you try to be a part of that
as we go forward well I mean in terms of
those jobs at our open
buck you know I it's not telling me to
tell us outta school that the teams are
obviously very good that they are ready
to win one was one win shy of winning
but the jobs are important certainly the
one in Houston
because whoever takes it
has got to change opinions of fans and
has got to change maybe a culture in the
building and I'm wondering what you
might bring to that equation well you
know yeah I remember I always try to
think these things realistically rich
and not get caught up in a lot of stuff
out there as you do it you know I always
felt like there was a lot of
professional entity of the Astros you
know you just say one they beat a lot of
people and we all questioned I think
that we're not willing to do ourself or
may not understand and you know
analytics are a big part of our game but
they're also something that's been
around for a long time we just have this
depends on what how you want to wait it
how do you want to what do you want to
use we're all using basically some of
the same measuring tools
why did 14 teams finish under 500 last
year and I'm getting off your question
about not but you know it's an honor to
have your name out there but it's also
with a little bit of okay at at what
price you know I I know got a pretty
good idea what's what has gone on and
what and it's it's a very unique set of
situations that are out there now that a
lot of anchors haven't walked through in
having you know I think about the things
I've been through with mr. Stryver a
probation heck I got thrown out of
baseball for a couple days for
testifying in a Steve Hal
Inquisition and went through the riots
with nobody there and Baltimore and keep
going so but this is unique you know
these are someone's going to have to
really measure their words and I
understand that the impact it has and
also try to you know lead some guys
through a situation that I think a lot
of them don't really completely
understand what's coming their way and
understand it's self-inflicted so you
just have to worship Thanks
yeah I mean talking to players and what
they're saying publicly it just seems
some you know it isn't and and I'm
wondering what the role of a manager is
in in that because you know you got to
find out what's gone on there and what
the players did or may not have done and
then how can we button it up so you can
start playing baseball the manager and
I've talked to AJ he's
you know it's a long story but we all
evolve and learn for things but I think
I got a pretty good idea what what went
on there and what happened how it got to
that point but it's going to take a very
constant message and you know you're
going to have to turn the cheek a lot
but at the end of the day you are going
to be able to control some things at
some point as Mattingly used to say
they're going to play that song they're
gonna play the anthem and you have an
opportunity to go out there and and and
get back to why remember why you do what
you do and there's such a lure that
competitive level to try to get every
edge you know but it's kind of like the
kid that comes out of police academy and
he has been taught the proper way to
treat the public and uh you know read
somebody there Miranda you know and how
to treat you know people with traffic
stops and also they sticking with a bad
veteran cop and the veteran cops that I
don't worry about and I'll show you how
to set up criminals I'll show you how to
to get free coffee whatever and next
thing you know the guy thinks that's the
way you're supposed to do it and you
know that's what's so when managers and
people are so protective of who they
allow in a clubhouse and how they set
that culture you know that's why because
a lot of young play we were able to
bring up Manny Machado and John scope
and all these young kids because we had
JJ Hardy we had Adam Jones
we had Nick Markakis we had Matt Wieters
and we're going to show them the right
way to do things okay I'm done that with
a ramp no no no but it's interesting how
you what you were saying their buckets
certainly in the fact that you you know
and again here's the thing I want you to
get this job this is the job that you
you want and I want you to get back on
the field I'm so partial to you but I
mean when you say you do know maybe what
was going on there you had a sense of
because you were in another Clubhouse
there's lots of room with lots of
innuendo and and then he's speaking to
Hinch in a way is there anything you can
share us or let me clarify sure let me
clarify you know I've got a feeling what
by the time you know you everybody so
you know you lose a three-game series
you get your brains beat out you know we
look home within then also someone's
kind of gonna hold something else going
on you know this certain telltale sign
what do you see
gasps Oh 12 straight fastballs in the
first changeup he throws the guys right
on it you all look at each other's
coaches I mean there's a checkpoint you
go through at least I did you know watch
a person third-base coach make sure
nothing's going on there i watch their
catcher be set up early this and that
whatever watch on deck hitters I watch
body language other dugout you just do
it it's a habit because you know you're
not paranoid you're alert to the things
that have gone on through your career
that you got to watch you know we do
what Burley was throwing one day at
Texas Stadium years ago because boots on
the ground advanced scout said something
he was doing with his glove we look for
well I think it's even the dugout but
you can't see from the batter's box so
there's a lot of things ago but that was
done by human beings
scouting watching said look for this it
might be there and it was there and
that's a whole different whole different
dynamic Buck Showalter here on the Rich
Eisen show okay now let's let's move on
then you were Derek Jeter's first
manager you were the guy in the
clubhouse when when Jeter first came it
was he wearing two at the time when he
first walked into the bat right question
I know we sent clubhouse one day on I
forget for the day game was over getting
ready calling up and make Peoria the
clubhouse guy who took PC he's placed in
there since Babe Ruth and I stick knock
on our sit down so what number are we
going to give this guy we thought a lot
of digit yeah he might have had a
go-between that's a great question I
just wonder I think we're looking it up
right now I just thought maybe you would
know that but you hurt you you were
there when they were discussed and let's
give him a single-digit yeah I wish I
told stick I said listen if it doesn't
work out this guy we're gonna be down at
Dixie Highway anyway I'm gonna be
somebody else from getting out at Jersey
well worked out it worked out
when was was the first time well when
when did when did when did one would do
first
I guess lay eyes on Jeter and was it
obvious that he had then he had
single-digit uniform or instructional
exactly managers you had to go to
Scott's like Brian Butterfield who still
coaches the big leagues now until Matt
Wright was with him Greensboro I think
he made 56 years that year
structurally has the butter what do you
think it because gonna be a big leaguer
impacts worked up for a long time ago
really he's got a little footwork issue
were going to fix here I thought a 7:15
in the morning I member landfill 76 but
Brian Butterfield working on footstep
its footwork but most funny is later on
every wants a lot of a twenty nannies
Derek would look over at me and add up
as a system manager and do that old
habit with his feet how he would you
know always drop step and we were
getting more time in uh in high school
you could do that but and just to tweak
me just to remind me that yeah I used to
do this so yeah coaching this reporter I
love it I love it so so then he came up
and these I mean obviously the cup of
coffee how do you think that helped him
get ready to be an AL Rookie of the Year
the next year you know you know he said
later I thought was kind of cool it's
the heck I thought that's where the
Yankees were supposed to be every year
that time right and and II like Rivera
we activate I'm the grief we took for
taking Rivera but then what I know now
what are using what do you mean or do
what do we in the great lot what are you
what do you mean the grease that you
took what are you talking about no no we
was a young up-and-coming kids they
didn't think he should be on the
postseason roster Rivera right I mean we
there's a lot of talk about jumping the
gun on how much it took a more veteran
presence but as far the gig but you know
watching their eyes light up during the
game during that whole September run I
remember I told Derek and those guys are
called looking guys if I hear you're on
the streets here in New York you know
you guys going down construction Utley
Derek something later said they didn't
leave the hotel room for three weeks
well like I said he obviously took all
that to heart
here buck shelter on the Rich Eisen show
what do you remember out Larry Walker
tell me why you think he might be Hall
of Fame worthy and that he's finally
right now twice a ground ball up the
middle for a double and of course he
opened the center fielder had in place
would be mental people to this great
base runner not
based on great based on the rich okay I
got a good one Larry Walker so okay
we're playing him in Utica New York the
Oneonta Yankees versus a co-op team okay
one of the Bret brothers is managing it
he's on first base he's a 17 year old
kid out of Canada you could tell he's
raw guy hits a long fly ball left center
field and Corey builts runs it down he
goes
3/4 away almost a third base and now
he's got to retrace his steps and go
back to pole rich he ran right across
the mouth across the field and he could
come on and every time I speak any
breath it was Kenny yeah I tell that
Larry he tells that Larry Walters store
I said you were some coach you know just
course oh God and now he's now he's in
Cooperstown
that's another plane god bless it should
be I thought she might get in I was open
I got a he that's Victor ever head rich
is that right all things considered one
game Curt Schilling and I had him when
he was hurt
I've never seen a guy locate a fastball
like that Curt had a game how long could
he pitch without throwing a breaking
ball but he had four four fast balls
because he could throw him to all four
quadrants and it was fun to watching
once he got that split it was over or
once he figured out how split it was
Katie bar the door
so you're saying buck showalter out of
your 24 years in managing okay that
you're the best pitcher you ever had if
you got to win one game you put
Schilling on the mound yep you do not
stutter why I'm good with cones right
there it comes there Randy Johnson I was
fortunate to have some good ones passed
my way but chilly just I don't know yeah
I mean hey flip a coin between all those
guys no I know that I know that when I
get just like what was he like game day
I mean
mental oh my gosh right it was you know
it was great for him he was great for
Randy hitch of eight innings estate all
what and Randy's pitch next day he
walked by and dug I go hey top that when
he big tall blankety-blank so I can walk
up a dugout and he story
now he's just rip-roaring he was great
for Randy okay they fed off each other
you know when we traded for him he was
hurt
I never Joe Guercio and I'm talking back
and forth he said well he's hurt us and
Joe if he's healthy we can't trade for
it mmm he's not going to be as amiable
you know I mean you know Joe was great
weather we pushed it through and got the
deal done and unfortunately I went there
for the hear what he was healthy I know
that man buck I mean I remember you
telling me the story you basically
helped designed what was then the bank
one ballpark I mean you got the
Diamondbacks off the ground you know
yeah you know we got there there was an
interior I said you know guys like 380
390 I said you know the olden wants his
great trainers here zone ball kind of
philosophy we gotta give her guys
somewhere a place to pitch dude I never
I came back Japan Korea trip I was
trying to get it zero I got thrown out
of the country for that one fact before
he was it zero but I come back and they
said hey come look at the South Poles
but they had put him in concrete no
netting was in foul ground we had to
break all the concrete spin the foul
poles around but it was cool watching
that go up you know you're getting all
rich with stadiums you remember as zoo
are being torn down yes so I got asked
what do you mean you almost got thrown
out of the country for Ichiro what are
you talking about what's apologies I got
him to take I got him take a picture in
a Diamondback Jersey hey you talk
Michael Jordan you talk anybody you want
to hear man Jarreau was bigger in Japan
right there's anything like it so I got
him to take a picture in a Diamondback
Jersey worked out that they thought I
was kind of stealing and taking back to
the states and all that stuff and it
wasn't good let's keep it that way
security had to be called to get to the
airport I was taking it's like taking
the prize you know idle out over the
country and that wasn't comfortable I
could tell you that he and Matsui were
so much better than everybody else
they were like light years better
everybody thought they could just take
another step down but the level tweeted
show of Matsui to their
exposition player was a huge drop quite
big leagues to double-a and the most
talented player you ever had any more
and the most talented player you ever
had was Deon Wright most talented oh
good it could have been if he'd been
baseball all the way people this guy
could throw he had some pop I mean he
got in a cage about three years ago in
Baltimore hit two home runs yeah he was
a and guys who played with him baseball
was over it's over he was her favorite
teammate he was a different guy on
baseball and I tell you story he called
him up to the big leagues he was with me
in double-a and they called me some on
Dion come up and try and help this
whatever so I called him biani the same
thing every night for tops baked beans
some kind of coleslaw so I called to
tell him if he goes his wife's
girlfriend what I I'm not sure maybe
fiance picked up the phone I said hey
can I speak yeah I'm plating right now
but yeah I think it's on the phone at
the end listen I call you they want you
to go up and this matter goes [ __ ] you
know it's for Tennessee because you
don't really don't want to go Triple A
you know I love the guys here we go
chance to win I just and so staging out
here you know an apartment at the end
we're talking about New York are you
talking about Columbus I tell you what
he dropped those pork chops in south
door in about two hours
[ __ ] you were the best man we cared
about it you are the best
thanks for the call let's chat soon and
hopefully whatever you wish to happen
happens you know that hey there's a lot
of quality people out there when they
say to be careful what you wish for you
never know but life's about know if jobs
are open on sounds well buck I hope you
get the challenge like I said if that's
what you wish we'll chat soon okay well
what the challenge is talking to you
today but we'll get through it now
unless you're happy you got straight
through it that's bucks y'all to
everybody for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app